We'll take advantage of what
the framework offers
in order to build our SettingsActivity.
Since we're supporting
Gingerbread devices,
we'll use a preference activity class.
If you're targeting Honeycomber later,
you'll want to use
the PreferenceFragment class.
Create a new SettingsActivity class
from the gist provided below.
Update the AndroidManifest
to declare this new activity.
You can see the way detail activity
is declared as an example.
If you see that APIs are deprecated,
that's okay. That's a side effect
of using PreferenceActivity,
in order to target Gingerbread devices.
When you create your app
for your final project,
you can use the wizard in Android Studio
to create a new SettingsActivity.
The code the wizard provides
will make your app backward compatible,
by using a combination
of preference activity
and PreferenceFragment.
Our gist is meant to be
a simplified version of that
for learning purposes. So later,
you'd be able to understand better
what the wizard is doing.
Check these items off
when you're done.